I accept that across all of that
viewership I have perhaps possibly maybe
said one thing or maybe two that has
upset a large range of people if I was
breaking laws I'd be in jail trust me I
drive at the speed limit my friend why
they can't put you in jail if you're
innocent yes they [ __ ] can
Andrew Tay has been arrested but the
main street narrative makes no sense
this is Tate predicting his arrest
around a month before it happened the
only thing I'll State this at the
beginning the only reason I'm upset by
being canceled is because I've expired
one of my lives because first you get
canceled then they make up a reason to
put you in jail and if that fails to
kill you so now I'm down to my last two
lives which is also why while I'm
answering this question I'm still being
careful how I'm answering them I'll tell
you scary it's scary because they've now
they've given me the warning and I'm
still running my mouth yeah so that's
scary one month later this happened now
the online influencer Andrew Tate has
been detained in Romania as part of a
human trafficking and rape investigation
Mr Tate was arrested as was his brother
Tristan when his house was ready in the
capital Bucharest the lawyer well a
controversial online influencer and
self-confessed misogynist is facing
charges this morning for human
trafficking rape and organized crime the
controversial social media influencer
Andrew Tate has been arrested in Romania
on suspicion of human trafficking rape
and forming an organized crime group and
as he was being taken away by Romanian
police he had one final message to say
to the world The Matrix has attacked me
on one hand Tate's got a good points
you're gonna try and put me in jail
they're gonna kill me and I would never
kill myself under any circumstances ever
and the reason I say this and I say
these people they go but what can they
put you in jail for and I'm like how
ignorant are you in your ignorance to
believe they need a reason you believe
it's fair you believe I can get a lawyer
and prove myself innocent that's not how
it works they decide you're guilty long
before and they find a reason why and it
doesn't matter what you do about it you
will pay the price it's not fair none of
it is every single system's corrupt it
actually annoys me when people say it to
me well just kill look why they can't
put you in jail if you're innocent yes
they can on the other hand he asked us
some questionable things that don't make
him look very good so is he guilty did
The Matrix really send their agents will
tape be suicided soon stay dangerous and
this is what we know so far
Tate became the most famous person in
the world because of this one genius
strategy he would get his fans to buy
his course Hustlers University then he
offered them 25 for every sale they got
for his course and then he taught them
step by step how to create their own
viral Andrew Tate fan page on Tick Tock
that way the more tick tocks they posted
the more money they made and the more
famous take god it worked out so well
that one affiliate was making over
eleven thousand dollars in one week but
sadly Tay had the closest affiliate
program so you can't join it anymore but
if you're interested in doing something
like this to make money we just launched
our own affiliate program just like his
from the master class we sell except
instead of paying you 25 per sign up you
get paid four times that at around a
hundred dollars per sign up and just
like today we also teach you how to edit
the tick tock switch Clips to use best
practices and more click the link below
to watch the first lesson of our master
class for free and buy now
when Tate was a broke kickboxer he got
sick of being broken he came up with his
plan to make his riches a webcam
business it would go on to make him rich
but it would also lay the foundation for
his human trafficking and organized
crime charges
it wasn't nearly as big and I found this
little webcam thing and I was like this
might be some money so I text all my
girlfriends I think it was five of them
text all five said you're all coming
here to live with me and work with me
none of them knew about each other
bro Tristan will tell you the story
he'll tell you all five flew in picked
them all up they're all sitting there I
sat around the same table
bro I didn't listen I need to get paid
right I'm broke now
I have no money I'm running out of money
so I put them over on the same table and
I was like look we're gonna start a
webcam business you're gonna stay you're
gonna live in London I'm gonna look
after you and we're gonna get rich rich
we're gonna be a team and they're all
like well who's this [ __ ] I'm like
she's my girlfriend she's my girlfriend
she's my girl you're all my chicks and
you're gonna stay here and we're gonna
make some money big fight kicks off blah
blah blah blah in the end long story
short free left two stayed those are my
first two girls and we started this
little webcam business from my apartment
and it just grew and grew and grew and
it got to the point where at one point I
had 75 women working for me in four
locations and I was doing 600 000 a
month from webcam
and although all of this does sound a
bit Shady technically there was nothing
illegal about his business and Tate was
in Paradise until one day A girl got too
drunk in his apartment made a mess and
refused to clean it up and that's when
Tay knew that he would have to teach her
a lesson
then I had one girl and she got too
drunk one day and she threw up in my
apartment I told her to clean up she
refused to clean up start being an idiot
so I took her stuff throughout the
window because it's like it's about that
with women you never hit a girl right
you can't do that but if we learned that
the hard way last week
but if all the other girls see me be
disrespected yeah they're gonna lose
respect for the facts right so she's
like I ain't cleaning that up you get
that so I'll say look I don't care and
she was my biggest earning girl she made
me on her own maybe 25 000 a month so I
didn't want to fire her and she knew I
didn't want to fire her which is more
reason why I had to fire her ass
so I was like all right cool you want to
be a gangster right you're a gangster
we're like high up like here it was just
out windows got hurt by her two arms and
marched her out the door locked the door
end of it he thought the ordeal was over
but months later the police came
knocking
she starts texting me texting me you owe
me my last month's wages you owe me my
money give me my money did I text her
back I ain't paying you nothing you
threw up my blood she went to the police
oh and told the police I hit her when I
didn't whoa so it's five in the morning
and this is about four months later five
in the morning four months later I'm
laying in bed I heard the door boom boom
boom boom and I don't know how I knew I
just knew it was police the way they
knocked that door I was like if you're
gonna rob me you kick the door in or you
this is just too obvious and as soon as
I heard that noise I just pause for a
second I heard please and I was like
but I didn't know what it was for right
but there's a few things I can't say in
the podcast I've done I've lived a
varied life right I've done some things
when I had to pay the bills right so I
was a bit like ah what's this gonna be
so I like flushed my phone down the
toilet quickly
I'm coming I'm coming
I'm looking around why do I have to hide
them eventually the door comes off the
hinges boom police bust in this alone
him in the meaning to Flushing his phone
down the toilet which is destroying
evidence this definitely doesn't help
his case and this run in what the law
would be will led him to move to Romania
he chose Romania because of his
Christian values before he converted to
Islam he chose Romania because of how
accessible corruption is there but
little did he know that that same
corruption would end up being directed
towards him
why do you choose to live there in
Romania yeah I know you I know you have
a lot of businesses and things going on
there but but why there because Western
Society is degraded and Western Society
is more corrupt so I think the Western
world there's something that I very that
very much angers me about the Western
World I don't feel comfortable here I
don't like the way it functions and
operates I think it's the most corrupt
disgusting degraded societies on Earth
there's nothing left besides money and
corporate agenda and I like living in
countries where one there's some kind of
moral fiber beyond the dollar and two I
like living in countries where
corruption is accessible for everybody
so in Romania where I happen to live as
the most Christian country on Earth
there's churches everywhere people see a
higher power beyond simply just money
and government they they believe in God
that's another reason I like spending
time in Dubai doesn't matter if it's
Allah or God or whatever you want to
call him I like that and also I like
Eastern Europe as a whole because
corruption is far more accessible I find
it offensive that a police officer in
England will stop me for speeding and
then refuse to take a bribe and pretend
that no no no but I'll tell you why
because he'll sit there and go no this
is the law law and order and pretend
that the law means something and and me
over but if you're a billionaire or if
you're Boris Johnson you can go to
Epstein's Island you can throw parties
during covid you know the [ __ ] you want
right so the whole the whole idea of Law
and Order is a Lie the whole idea of
it's bull it's just about if you're high
enough you can throw it all away I'd
rather be in a society where if I'm in
Prague and they stop me for speeding and
they say bro you were speeding you know
here's 50 bucks all right cool cool bye
bye if corruption exists which it does
let us all play why do only they get to
play and I don't get to play so you live
in England and they're going to come
around and spout Law and Order at you
all day long but the elites they ignore
all Law and Order it's always been it's
always been live
[Music]
thank you
fast forward to 2022 Tate becomes the
most viral man on the planet by calling
out the elites by calling out those in
power by calling out the Matrix these
people print money they're above money
right and they believe whoa I won't say
quite rightly but I understand why they
believe it that they're better than
everybody else they believe that they're
literally a different species than
everybody else we're peasants we're ants
we're nothing to these people so if they
tell you to do something you better do
it so if you stand up and say that's
dumb then I go whoa whoa whoa who's the
big mouth oh this ant's smart
and they'll find a way to check you
and uh if you're an ant that stands up
and then a whole bunch of other ants
stand up with you
well that's that's where the problems
come right that's why they got Socrates
you know why Socrates died I'd love to
I'd love to hear he he was arrested and
he ended up poisoning himself
and killing himself because they were
going to execute him and he was arrested
for corrupting the youth because he was
convincing the youth to think about not
joining the military because the wars
were pointless
so corrupting the youth is why Socrates
died if you make the you think you're an
enemy to The Establishment it's always
been the same
do you not go to bed at night sometimes
and
yourself
I'm yes
yes but at this point I've now made a
decision to stand true to my morals and
stand true to God and genuinely be a
force of good for the world and
genuinely try to make people do good
things to other people and if if I'm not
going to stop doing that so if I'm going
to die I'm going to die it's like being
in a plane crash what can you do
planes going down what are you going to
do about it you can scream and be a girl
about it but the plane's still going to
crash so it's kind of not defeatist it's
kind of like you come to terms
with the scenario am I going to sell my
soul and live longer and have less of an
impact on the world and know that I'm
aiding the devil in its intentions or am
I going to live a shorter amount of time
do my absolute best to be a positive
force for the world and be remembered as
such and I think that God will reward me
for that so it's just you come to terms
with the reality that there are enemies
too powerful to fight and there's
nothing you can do
August 2022 The Matrix hit back first he
got a strike on YouTube then his entire
digital identity was wiped out
overnights but their attempt to silence
tape backfired badly even more videos of
tape started popping up to get canceled
was the best publicity he's ever gotten
but as Tay explained he just used up his
first life much like Julian Assange of
WikiLeaks if you attack the system The
Establishment or the Matrix or whatever
you want to call it first though try to
cancel and discredit you I think he's a
bad guy I think the man is a high-tech
terrorist dead man can't leak stuff this
guy's a traitor a treasonous and and he
has broken every law of the United
States if you still don't quiet down
they'll accuse you of something that's
easy in the frame and unforgivable in
the eyes of the public like rape sexual
assault child pornography in the case of
Julian Assange he was accused of rape in
Sweden the charges were later dropped
nine years later after completely
ruining his life and once they accuse
you of some heinous crime they throw you
in jail if that doesn't work if you're
still a threat you'll probably go the
same way that every japstine wants with
10 Kate's first life gone and him only
getting louder afterwards it was time to
take away his second life
[Music]
since the day Tate kicked that girl out
of his apartment accusations have been
following him ever since and in April
2022 they came after him again a
complaint was made by a woman from the
U.S that she was called being forcibly
held at the resonance End quotes the
tape brothers were questioned by the
police for several hours but without any
clear evidence they were released again
they came into my house at 5 PM they did
a forensic search as they should at 8 pm
the search concluded they took me from
my house at 8 pm for paperwork at the
police station and by 9 21 I was back
home then in August the Romanian police
came to his house in Bucharest again the
accusations this time human trafficking
but once again it looked like a false
alarm were you arrested for human
trafficking what happened yeah I was not
arrested so what happened is I suffered
from a case of swatting it's very
popular with people who were large on
the internet many large YouTubers have
been swatted it's where you call the
police and you say somebody has a gun or
there's a hostage situation and the SWAT
team arrives somebody made a phone call
to the American Embassy saying that I
was holding women at my house the police
arrived and let me State this now I
State this uh openly to the world I have
absolute respect for the police I would
hate to live in a country where if you
call the police saying women are being
held against their will that the police
don't respond that would be terrible of
course they should come and look
absolutely they turned up they
investigated they realized that nobody
was in the house against their will
there was no crime committed they said
okay you're not a suspect but you are a
witness to this along with me my brother
the housekeeper uh The Gardener
everybody was in the premises at the
time was labeled a witness we had to go
to the police station for 45 minutes for
pieces of paper we filled them in and we
were let go so although Tate remained
free these allegations kept following
him everywhere rumors were spreading
that Tate was using the so-called
Loverboy method a human trafficking
tactic where you recruit female victims
by getting them to fall in love with you
dangling the promise of marriage and
Financial Security in front of them also
that you can exploit them later but
again for the longest time the
accusations didn't stick but in December
2022 something changed Tate was finally
arrested The Matrix has attacked me if
found guilty he's looking at three to
ten years for human trafficking alone
but when you start to look into it there
are a lot of holes in this narrative
[Music]
see Tate is no dundum why would he spend
all this effort to become famous why
would he make himself such a big Target
why would he openly brag that he lives
in Romania where you can literally find
his house on Google Maps by searching
for Hustler's University if he's
operating a human trafficking ring if
you were operating a human trafficking
ring would you spend your time calling
out governments and powerful people
trying to get more and more famous
with the scrutiny I'm under
does anyone think I'm breaking the law
a little scrutinized man on the planet
like if I was breaking laws
I drive at the speed limit my friend
that's the level it's got to like they
don't they think I'm out here doing bad
things so when they when their article
comes out saying Tate did this I I just
pray there's enough people who are
outside of the Matrix to sit and go this
is something and he doesn't deserve this
because I don't deserve it because I
will be innocent I mean if they were to
get me in some kind of legal trouble
they're going to try again with the
media machine Andrew Tate well-known
misogynist thief whatever they're gonna
say and they're gonna try and convince
the world of it the people who've been
canceled at my level there's only four
or five of them I think I'm the fit and
yeah I'm the last one who's managed to
stay all over the social networks but
the problem is that comes with its own
issues right because when the Matrix
cancels you you have it goes in three
stages first they try and shut you up if
that fails they try and put you in jail
for something you didn't do and if that
fails they kill you right so slowly
we're moving on to stage two I I knew it
was coming I absolutely not only knew it
was coming because of how orchestrated
it was the only thing I'll State this at
the beginning the only reason I'm upset
by being canceled is because I've
expired one of my lives because first
you get canceled then they make up a
reason to put you in jail and if that
fails to kill you for an intelligent guy
which I agree with you he is to be doing
the things he's being accused of doing
and then go seek publicity as a very
unwise move if he's did the thing
correct he did then then it's like what
you would think if you're committing
atrocities you would try to stay under
the radar he does quite the opposite
besides when you have this kind of
status as a man you don't need to hold
women against their will the women come
to you on their own free will a house
that hang out with them these guys are
celebrities in Romania guys women are
obviously going to flock towards them
but right with great anytime you're
famous anytime you have any type of
status any cloud or whatever people look
at that right to their own Advantage
people have nefarious intentions a lot
of time to get around people of status
and power and this is no different okay
men lie women lie numbers don't and
quite frankly people will do and say
anything to bring you down when you have
status and money to elevate themselves
like just use common sense do you really
think guys that have their influence
money status stature needs of traffic
girls for what like Common Sense do you
think that they need to trap for girls
it's like saying Hugh Hefner needs to do
that if anything they kick girls out
because there's too many and you guys
gotta understand that there is a huge
interest in painting these guys in a bad
light there's a huge interest in making
allegations against them there's a huge
interest in knocking them off the
platform getting them canceled and the
fastest way right to get someone jammed
up is quite frankly through women that's
the easiest way there have been women
that came forward and literally said
they were offering me 10 to 50 000 yep
to lie on Andrew and Tristan that I was
a victim of trafficking that I was raped
that I was assaulted Etc y'all are
telling me that there are if there's
women that came forward that admitted
yeah they offered me this money and I
declined it y'all are telling me there
aren't women that will accept it 100 but
just like how the U.S pressured other
countries like Sweden and the UK to
throw Julian Assange in prison so they
can extradite him to America the same
could be happening to Tate right now I
don't know what's happening right like
what is what what really happened and
why is why is Romania going after him
are they being pressured by someone else
to do this like what what is the reason
why they're doing it and what do they
have on him
[Music]
the thing you have to understand about
Romania is that it is corrupt to the
core it's one of the most corrupt
countries in Europe and everything is
for sale in Romania the police the
course everything and everyone can pay
for whatever they want in Romania if
they have the money it's probably why
Tate was able to register his compound
as a shooting range so he could have
guns and armed guards there everyone can
pay for whatever they want including the
us one of the corruptest countries in
the world is Romania you know how many
people message me yesterday from Romania
listen this place is corrupt that lawyer
on the Twitter spaces yesterday said the
following
he said everything in Romania is about
money everything so if you want to buy
them out to get out you can do it if
other countries want to buy Romania they
can do it wow if other countries want to
call Romania to say hey man you guys got
to get this thing scored away or else
we're not going to give you the
supporter we're not going to give you
this you have to do it so meaning if a
place like Romania can be bought to take
a guy like this down that is very
possible not saying that's what happened
that's very possible that's why A
well-connected source told Patrick about
David that the U.S embassy may have
pushed the Romanian police to arrest
hates I get a message this morning from
a guy that's very very connected in uh
the the the what's the word I'm looking
for he's very connected in law and um
FBI PD you know all Department of
Justice extremely qualified God I don't
want to give exactly what his job is
because you know who it is okay he said
the final one I saw the interviews last
night keep this in mind if you talk to
them they have to have probable cause to
do the war to do these warrants
the excuse that somebody made a
complaint and anonymous complaint
uh at that and they send a SWAT team to
his house as vote even though it's
Romania they still have laws in the U.S
embassy uh and the U.S embassy was
involved I think the embassy put them up
to it so there is no doubt that tay has
created some powerful enemies but
there's also a legitimate case against
Andrew Tates
foreign
[Music]
work as the following quote my job is to
meet a girl go on a few dates sleep with
her test if she's quality get her to
fall in love with me to where she'd do
anything I say and then get her on a
webcam so we could become rich together
End quotes
which no matter how you slice it sounds
a lot like the Loverboy method Tate also
lightly insinuated that one of the
reasons he moved to Romania was because
the rape laws were more lenient he
indicated in a statement that this is 40
of the reason why he left England to go
to Romania only 14 of the reason I moved
to Romania because in Eastern Europe
none of this garbage flies when people
say why did Romania and I explain my
five reasons one of them is the metoo
era think oh well you're a rapist I say
no I'm a [ __ ] rapist but I like the
idea of being able to just say to do
what I want I like being free this
probably wasn't exactly what he meant
but again it doesn't look good but this
wasn't the only time Tate was giving
away a little bit too much info here's
what an attorney had to say about Tate's
case five in the morning four months
later I heard the door and I heard
police there's a few things I can't say
in the podcast I've done I've lived a
varied life that is a form of cell
snitching that indicates that there's
things out there that are illegal that
he's done I've done some things when I
had to pay the bill what's this going to
be so I like flushed my phone down the
toilet quickly so I destroy evidence
just stuck in our house and they're
bored and of course they don't go out
they're not allowed out so I got all
these chicks they're in love with me
they don't go out they're not allowed
out that's coercion we're getting the
sex part start beating the Shag I'll
grab you by your neck start annoying me
trying to resist that is who he's gonna
be in order to control these women in
order to keep the money coming in
because he was broke before right but it
gets worse according to the times of
London one of his female's employees
brought in 54 000 per month but didn't
get paid well under Tate's quote house
arrest End quotes and there's also a
transcript of a conversation between
Tate and one of his victims quote you
have to understand that once you're mine
you'll be mine forever a woman never
leaves her man I would be the last man
in your life end quotes
Chloe can you be loving enough to be a
wife to always be by by side wherever I
go to talk to zero men besides me ride
or die you have to move to Romania with
me to keep an eye on you your mind do
not forget that and act like it we will
be together soon in quotes
again he didn't admit guilt in these
statements but again it doesn't look
good for him all of this wouldn't sound
too good in a court of law but let's be
honest right now no one knows what's
going on his dire fans and loyal friends
stand by him and say he wouldn't hurt
anyone and that all those women are
being bribed by the government to bring
Tate down and his haters are celebrating
his downfall after all he did say that
he doesn't have a squeaky clean past
there's a few things I can't say in the
podcast I've done I've lived a varied
life right I've done some things when I
had to pay the bills maybe his past is
coming to ha him even though he's not
doing anything illegal anymore from a
cult psychology marketing perspective
this idea of this perfect David and
Goliath story of The Matrix coming after
him for spreading the word of God is the
perfect narrative this story is changing
super fast Andrew Tate was apparently
taken to a hospital from his jail cell
so on account you may want to follow as
Tate's manager's Twitter where he just
shared a video where two of the six
alleged victims came out on TV to say
the allegations against the Tates are
false and that quote they are like
family with the tapes and quotes but one
thing is for sure if Tate is right if
it's true that the Matrix after him if
it's true that he just used up his
second life and is now on his third he
has said many times before that he will
never kill himself within three minutes
bro within three minutes with 150
different activists post basically the
same wording and slightly Rewritten in
the same picture there's somebody above
him behind all that so they decided
somebody whoever they are don't kill me
I'd never kill myself don't try but bro
because that's what's next that's what's
next it's scary I'm telling you everyone
thinks I'm paranoid everyone thinks I'm
crazy and I'm telling them to do the
opposite I'm telling them to think and
that's the last thing they want so they
decided ah Andrew is telling the
population that the subset of the
population that we're most fearful of to
think for themselves so Andrew has to go
and they attempted to cancel me they
have failed now I have to make sure they
don't try and suicide me that's the next
goal because what happens if you don't
shut up eventually that's what comes
next so for everyone watching at home I
would never kill myself it's the most
common tactic in the world first day
insult your character and attack you at
stage one of the three stage three
stages they attack you your character
and cancel you they put you in jail for
something you did not do and the last is
they kill you and I'll make it very
clear here I would never kill myself
under any circumstances ever ever and if
I like to think that if anybody sees a
media article where I've been locked up
for whatever it is they're going to look
at it and go this is bull Tate didn't do
that when the Matrix cancels you you
have it goes in three stages first they
try and shut you up if that fails they
try and put you in jail for something
you didn't do and if that fails they
kill you right and you can bet that
we're gonna make an update video as more
information comes out so make sure you
subscribe for part two
the main reason tape blew up was because
he got his fans to relentlessly post
tick tocks of them saying the most
insane stuff and he got his fans to do
this by paying them 25 for every sale
they got him for his course Hustlers
University people would buy his course
he would then provide them with super
detailed instructions on how to edit
tick tocks he provided a Google doc with
all the controversial clips of him he
basically handheld his fans on how to
create a viral amputate fan page so the
more viral tick tocks they posted of
them the more traffic they drove to
their affiliate link for his course and
the more money they made and it worked
insanely well one affiliate was making
over eleven thousand dollars in one week
and some were apparently making even
more than less but sadly Tay had to
close off his affiliate program so you
can't join it anymore but lucky for you
I'll just launched our own affiliate
program and to make it even sweeter than
Tates instead of just getting 25 dollars
per sign up you can earn four times that
at around a hundred dollars per sign up
and we also have step-by-step lessons
teaching you how to post with our shorts
and tick tocks of my videos as exactly
like Tate did we teach you how to edit
them with completely free video editing
software which Clips to choose best
practices we give you all the shortcuts
our masterclass is called Financial
slavery masterclass and it's perhaps my
greatest body of work yet 20 plus
lessons all narrated by me in the same
documentary style you've come to love
and it's about how all the most powerful
governments and corporations today are
successful because they exploited this
one secrets and how you too can use this
one secret to gain more money in power
what is the secret you may ask well
you'll have to watch our first lesson
for free with the link below to find out
all I can say is there has never been a
course like this ever made so on top of
the 100 affiliate program you're also
going to be learning the truth of the
world that everyone is too afraid or too
ignorant to say out loud so click the
link below by the masterclass and become
an affiliate now
foreign
[Music]